joey diaz called me this morning what's
good you know and you guys look up to
him i know
and so he called me this morning he's
like what's good [ __ ] you know so
yeah you talk to a lot of like um like
comedians off off of the pod he calls
like once a week oh yeah yeah he's just
like that and he's always got you know
for him everything is three things it's
a uh
it's destination a sandwich and
something to read every time he tells
you information he's like dude here's
what you do
you're in buffalo you go two blocks down
there you're gonna smell a guy right
don't look at him all right to the left
you're gonna see a uh a sandwich shop
looks like it's out of business you
[ __ ] go in there right you order you
order a uh rube and ask for four extra
inches of meat crack open a a copy of
catcher in the rye and you're [ __ ]
tremendous son every time no matter
where you are he's like oh you're in
tampa go until you can't [ __ ] see
anything right turn around three times
there's gonna be a lady there with a
[ __ ] uh
you know a couple of uh loose veal you
know you grab one of those [ __ ] man
you know you open a copy of time
magazine from 1979. oh nobody can [ __ ]
with you
[Music]
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way i
know
[Music]